garçon bleu donc on va voir si elle veut
si il est pas trop grand sinon j'irai
chercher le nom de la foi
et je recherche une tenue donc en fait
les tenues on peut en avoir des toutes
faites là dans le rayon
bon c'est ça un peu plus que je
travaille pas je n'ai pas le revenu bon
ça me aide plus à par rapport à
les vêtements
[Musique]
donc elle prend du lait toujours 2e âge
les couches taille 4 5
alors ce sont pour la plupart ça veut
dire 90 %
des mamans qui sont
sans papier ou qui sont venus sans
papier alors soit de différents pays il
y a pas beaucoup de personnes d'origine
qui sont françaises parce que parce que
tout simplement à partir du moment où
elles viennent nous restait au bébé
c'est qu'elles n'ont aucun revenu or en
France on donne des allocations
familiales donc elle n'aurait pas le
droit à venir en resto du coeur des
moments plus recevons sont au départ
sont peut-être étaient en détresse et
maintenant avec avec le temps si vous
voulez se confie beaucoup donc une
espèce de confiance qui s'est instauré
entre entre elles et nous il y a une
douzaine de bénévoles ici de bénévoles
de qualité en ce sens qu'elles sont des
bénévoles qui sont pédiatres psy
directrice de crèche enfin il y a des
tas de métiers
[Musique]
est-ce que vous savez un manteau chaud
juste ça
[Musique]